[Music]
in [ __ ] up news ooh
submitted by Cory female lol oh nice
Cory was ok with the ie oh that's pretty
the kie that's cute oh that is really
cute
great name co-parents police are
investigating a nursing home after a
woman in a vegetative state gave birth
it's a miracle
no no cuz I was putting it together I
was like wait how is she [ __ ] on that
means she was still and some doctor bill
my name is but I like the [ __ ] coma
Davis date is different yeah slightly
different there's so many miracles that
are happening right now ok one she's a
senior citizen how do you know there's
little old people right no nursing home
takes care of any age that need help
like that's what we need you here dude
they'll be like a 30 year old person
like say there really had really bad
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in their brain or
something like they'll stay in your
nursing home probably got to half legs
why is it then every time I go to a
nursing home is full of old people
yeah same yeah this one it's uh it's
called Hacienda skilled nursing facility
and they specialize in nursing people
that are under the age of 45 years old
and so this woman she's 29
I've been in a vegetative state for over
a decade after a drowning incident oh
man well you could DNA test the baby
right yeah that's exactly what they're
doing right now police are demanding DNA
samples from all the male staff did the
coma wake up the lady I mean the giving
birth wake up the ladies so let me
explain coma you're pretty much
unconscious like you're not completely
aware vegetative state your brains did
yeah if she's if she's gonna drown like
sheep I'll drown
victim she probably had oxygen
deprivation and so her brains is dead
yeah so vegetative say this person is
still unconscious they have no awareness
of themselves or the environment the
main difference between coma and the
vegetative state is that at some point
the person's eyes will be open and there
will be times when they seem to be awake
they may move parts oh my god movement
is not voluntary movements can include
grinding their teeth thrashing and
facial movements such as grimacing
yawning or smiling why keep them over
why keep them alive that's that's [ __ ]
up yeah people do it because it's no
moral argument because it isn't my
understand a coma because there's people
that wake up from comas
I just don't last that long - we found
out comas typically are only for like up
to three weeks or four weeks if it's
beyond that it's not a coma what is it
then because some people wake up after
like five years in a coma they say five
years ten years in a kolbe it is but
then they're saying like what we looked
up it's like typically comas only lasts
like a short period of time if people
are in a coma right there are so many
stories where in ten years over 15 years
there's a miracle and they wake up and
they're fine they're like oh my god this
is crazy that's cool right don't pull
the plug but if they're in this
vegetative state and you know for sure
that they're Gonzo's and there's no way
they're gonna wake up that's like
trapping the [ __ ] soul true but
then what about it like religiously
that's why I'm saying you're trapping a
soul well no I mean but then for you to
pull the plug on someone you're
basically saying okay to killing someone
that's not dead I think it's playing God
to keep him alive maybe but I'm just
saying like I guess the other side of
the the coin what do you mean so what's
their argument since we have the
technology we should keep him alive yeah
because because if it was their time to
pass away they would have passed God
would have taken the whole body and the
whole soul if he wanted to right like
that's that I think that other side like
we shouldn't decide yep my God says
music technology is interfering with
God's nature right that's how there's
two sides then my side of the coin it
feels very bad feels very bad that a
vegetative person is kept alive because
you know what I imagine that person is
like [ __ ] remember that movie with
Jordan Peele [ __ ] you kid
I feel that there's a little person
inside saying I'm your friend right and
I go you die both Bart and I pass away
now passed away but he passes away I'm
in a vege of you're the next in line to
make the life decision right that's the
scenario yeah but I've told everyone in
this room that no matter what happens
don't pull the plug or the plug and
medicine and technology so depending on
what state vegetative vegetable you are
like you sure care to run yeah like if
you're like it's a frontal cortex team
or a cerebellum fear or whatever thing
like the advancements of technology
they're able to cure different phases of
it so some people are like just keep
them around for five years because we
can't heal this guy or ten years or
whatever so if it's healable of course
I'm not gonna but we don't know what
what is or is not because the technology
advances [ __ ] I don't know what yeah
and then the knowledge changes right
yeah well this lady has been in a
vegetative state for more than a decade
I said nearly a decade for 14 years yeah
yeah damn [ __ ] and she she was 15 by the
way if I'm in a vegetative state pull
that [ __ ] pin no we're keeping
you alive coma no but coma opposite
opposite of what we are coma keep me
alive I'm pulling the plug you don't get
to make these decisions okay something
happens to you in the scenario king of
jamali our lives on yeah oh now you're
on his side you so [ __ ] king of do
you know this man
no this guy came around all right when
I'm when I'm in my coma pregnant
yourself only if it can get hard you
can't get hard I don't know what to do
the places but I'll try viagra in his
mouth it's biological you could just
stick a syringe in my ballsack and
[ __ ] suck out the sperm just do that
I like the way his biology work okay I
think there's no sperm in your ballsack
I think it's actually in your lower
stomach yeah your math dude I forgot I
don't know I don't know I just wanted to
say that I knew that it wasn't really in
the ball it's not in the pool like what
it sounds smart I don't know but if it's
is the tool what does the pause do maybe
it's just like a temporary hold before
the I don't know it's like a bomb where
the two ingredients have to get together
oh yeah oh my god sure there's there's
even in the boss right you clicked on
this video and I wanted to hear about
the [ __ ] lady because if you don't
cover the one you feel heavy balls I
feel like my balls are heavier if I
don't feel the weight on my shoulders if
I roll
hey [ __ ] bust some night their life's
gonna be death huh yeah maybe that's why
my shoulders hurting tell we have sex in
the lobby shoulders super tense have a
baby so she had a baby boy people it's a
baby house Americal oh I know it's crazy
you can't even push or anything with
that section it just comes out actually
they didn't say how the baby was well
done' they said that a nurse delivered
the baby so what happened here was that
they didn't know that she was pregnant
until she was in labor oh my god moaning
and like oh my gosh so she felt all the
pain no no I think what we were saying
what tip was trying to explain is that
when you're a vegetable you still your
body still responds to pain but you're
not conscious of the pain like you don't
know you're in pain you know my brain
has no activity well yeah the body has
like has responses so the the receptors
of the nerves it's not like trigger it's
not like connecting but your body
actually feels the pain that's [ __ ]
crazy oh my god yeah a nurse that was on
staff that during that time like
delivered the baby boy and so now her
family is saying that who donger boy is
like he's born into a loving family like
he's gonna be raised by the family hell
no I reject the [ __ ] out of that kid
it's not the kids fault should a [ __ ]
unclog me once they see the baby once it
gets past his purple state they'll see
the ethnicity throw so they could narrow
it down like that right the like it's an
Asian baby we don't need to wait for the
[ __ ] baby and it changes cost too
much money just life it's not that much
you could just do 20 DME so obviously
when it comes out in a couple weeks it's
like $20 the beautiful the beautiful
fluffy black hair
obviously the couple hours a few minutes
if it's got that purple thing on its
back then
it's a Mongolian baby that's right Oh Oh
does he still have it should be gone
yeah I don't think he has it in him yeah
Oh crazy yeah he had the Mongolian
marked it looks like a little bruise on
his butt oh yeah pretty cute yeah so the
ik he came to stamp certified tiny stamp
sir has one but it's not purple it's
like a lighter shade of his skin
oh yeah have that too so that's just
because that was original color is
disappearing dude
did they find who the raper was like
this this was your photo mug is my baby
well yeah this cord wrapped around his
neck what do you think all right sure
whatever just do what the [ __ ] joke
all right anyway what was your question
they do not find the person yet as of
right now they haven't they're just
doing all the DNA tests well they're
requesting or whatever you know legality
and it whichever one guy doesn't show up
for work just know yeah so immediately
after they found this out they change
their policies in their facility where
no longer is the male staff allowed to
be alone in a female patients room
unless they're accompanied by female
stuff so I thought that was already a
lot it's a lot of a lot of doctor
practices because of cases like the
doctors are just scared or yes my my
OBGYN always came in the room with the
female nurse always so that's why I
always felt really comfortable cuz I
don't I just had the biggest fingers out
ever seen wait who's your doctor
Mitri my do and love it we have the same
fingers in her vagina oh you guys got
the same Arnaz fingers yeah I see his
hands I don't mind you better not do you
see that [ __ ] you better those bats eyes
he's like this six foot five [ __ ] 300
bill looks like [ __ ] bear claws the
donuts
where it's [ __ ] like
that's [ __ ] five Twinkies on each
Chinese no saw I love him he's the best
here the gap and look that's your
[ __ ] before second so huge my god
it's like uh Jesus
[Music]